welcome
a movie channel and stormy has got
covered so we doused him in bleach and
sent him home
um because that's that's what you do
when somebody's got covered right you
put each other
and lock them in a room
um but he's absolutely fine he's just
got a bit of a cough so he didn't want
to come and cough and splutter on our
video this sci-fi sunday but harris
our second
resident american has joined us
on our video this sci-fi sunday but
harris
a second
yeah you need to turn that off first
i just realized that real fast
muted
we're good
excellent excellent right so are we
oh say hi harris how you doing lindsay
howdy how's everybody doing we're very
good very good um you had a lovely
weekend away in vegas last week and you
had such fun you can't tell us anything
about it i believe
that sounds about right and i might get
myself
what happens if vegas stays in vegas uh
i can't wait to go back um i'm gonna
i've got a pal who's a big poker game
player and every year he gets like this
close to going to the poker stars and
it's like when you go i i'm i'm there
i'm with you so
i will return to vegas that's the way to
do it i can't game over the damn but
yeah i know he's pretty good
um the crazy thing about vegas
crazy
so they got these um
at the
i was just walking along the street and
some guy goes in coca-cola
uh bottled water cocaine
i'm like what was that last one
it's a mad city
but anyway this week we are talking star
wars because
on a live video a couple of weeks ago
you said
um that you can talk about star wars
forever
and you have to say that all the
politics of star wars you just go on and
on and on
to which i went there are no politics in
star wars you're talking crap
so
you're a young lad you you you don't
know the ways of the world yet so
if i say you're talking crap you must be
right because that's how
something like that it's not like i was
raised in oil country and had to deal
with politics all too long i i like to i
like to be uh inside of it and know
what's going on sometimes
politics sucks just uh
yeah politics does suck it's going to be
a bit above both bob from what i'm told
but i mean
harris you are taking the lead on this
one because as i say i think you're
talking rubbish so you have to convince
me
so
well
we'll get to the the non-politics in
star wars because that's kind of where
we're at now
where we i guess andor is going to bring
us into a
little bit more of the politics within
what's what's going on in the world of
star wars at the moment
or what was going in to make the
original trilogy etc etc uh okay but at
the moment i think mostly with disney
star wars they have avoided politics i
mean some sometimes for good reason but
politics is what like
makes star wars star wars at the end of
the day besides the
like the taoism and the taoism of like
the force essentially politics is the
other like driving narrative behind the
entire series
uh and
that i think is we can get into that a
little later but uh i believe that's
where the sequels and and some of the
other things disney has done is kind of
faltered is that it has lost the
politics completely and it just
blatantly tells you good side bad side
focus on these people don't focus on
these people you know that's why
yeah
where
even in the original trilogy
it's it's pretty black and white uh it
gets skewed a lot more in the prequels
which is fun to watch but uh the og
trilogy is definitely um
good guys versus bad guys but you get to
see vader's whole arc throughout that
and get to see some of the good within
the bad and see how even like the worst
of people can be redeemed from both
their politics and life decisions etc
there's
there's a lot of politics out there but
where'd you want to start do you want to
start with the original
i'd say freaking i can start talking
about oh geez
where you going to start chronologically
yeah so i mean
generally i i'd say
what i wrote down was star wars is
george lucas versus populism
okay
and that goes
it's shown differently both in the
prequels and the og trilogy
not so much in the sequel trilogy but
in the first two uh the prequels in the
original there is populism both in uh
the
i i i've seen a couple good titles i
guess in the way it's uh presented
but the prequels are how liberty dies
and the original trilogy is how liberty
is reborn
and i think that's a good way of just
summing it up because you get to watch
a shaky republic i guess turn into
the empire
bit by bit and and you get to see i
guess the bureaucracy behind it and that
is where i guess people kind of faltered
on liking the phantom menace and attack
of the clones and
rivender the sith definitely gives it
action but that's where it gets slower
and it takes time to delve into those
politics
um
it's
i mean
for me the republic was
brought out because is it supposed it's
supposed to be democracy
isn't it
because they're all in the senate and
they're also like
we can't have a democracy in this
country with like 300 people with a vote
that bloody hall where they've got
thousands i mean what the smeg
i mean um
hey rodrigo good afternoon sir oh
i i need a better name rodrigo is such a
cool name i mean jamie's such a crap
name but um you can do cool stuff with
it though
uh i'm jay as simple as i know
the little members emoji has to be made
now i'm just saying
um
so what was i saying so so yeah so i
mean i i always wondered
how that would work you know one of the
things of star wars that i've always
wondered those is that the empire seems
far better funded and far better
supported than the republic ever was
there's a deleted scene uh
and i mean there's a bunch of deleted
scenes but one of the things i guess
that is
that stays in the film is uh
bail organa leia's adoptive father is
he's part of the i believe it's 2000
delegates kind of against palpatine but
there's a there's a full undeleted scene
that's a great scene
um where it's bale padme mon mothma and
then three other senators i can't
remember their names i i know a lot of
the names not all of them uh
but they're all sitting in a room and
they're essentially discussing how
palpatine has now put in place where
the empire because okay so in the clone
wars do you remember
you've seen the television series right
yeah
uh do you remember after the embara arc
which is a great arc where they're going
to that cool planet all the people uh
poncrell is there with the two
double-bladed lightsabers and all that
yeah
clones take out a jedi all that kind of
stuff but in a good manner actually um
in a nice way
yeah that's that's a whole different
aspect of politics i don't even think
about talking about that but uh
that arc
i guess precedes the
moon arc which is remember who darth
plagueis is
and uh
palpatine's master i know i'm going all
over the place oh okay no problems
master that rings about yeah the the
story of darth vader i like star wars i
don't
like
star wars we stop at star trek all damn
day and i will tell you every subplot of
every back character and thing but star
wars you'll have to walk me through a
little bit i need a star trek game and
you know these things yeah yeah yeah you
do need to start well you need to come
and use our gate lesson more than else
i gotta
oh yes you picked a team sir available
on sidethistrick.com
yeah right
um
so anyway sorry sorry i interrupted you
yeah you know so uh i guess the the
whole mune arc is where the munes are
you can see them in
attack of the clones whenever uh
obi-wan is on geonosis and he's watching
count dooku talk to all those
separatists
and
they are one of the peop one of the
species i guess represented in that
separatist movement
initially and they are the banking clan
so whereas the separatists are getting
that whole they're getting corporations
to join them it's like that's where it's
iffy because you get corporations that
have
uh political power in the senate and
those corporations are the ones that are
of course
bring everything to fold with the trade
federation with the phantom menace with
the blockade turning into all-out war
and naboo
uh the the furtherment of that though is
the banking clan is behind palpatine
palpatine's master darth plagueis
was one of the banking clan like not
founders or masters or anything like
that but he was uh
on on their board and one of their heavy
board members is a good way of saying
that
and
he puts in place i just love that idea
of like a darth sit darth maul you know
at the end of a long table um what's for
lunch
because that's all the people when
you're in this board meeting that's all
you really give a [ __ ] about
coffee
who's going out for baguettes uh yeah so
pokemon sorry
yeah no uh
he
he essentially
that's a whole different topic i can go
into palpatine versus plagueis all day
but palpatine uses plagueis plan
and
that he's had for hundreds of years and
to do everything he's doing
makes it even better and you know taking
out his master and doing his own stuff
but
the he in in doing all of that palpatine
has taken
the banking clan from itself uh
essentially with
with the republic after the umbara arc
and all that
full circle sorry an 80d i'll go all
over the place
after the umbara arc the mewnark happens
and
essentially the clones are sent to mune
where the banking clan is and
it's shown that the banking plan was
supporting the separatists more more so
than they were the republic and there
wasn't so much a neutrality which is you
know a common thing that pops up in the
clone wars
and
that is what sets everything forward
through through the very acting speed
now through the bureaucratic side with
bail organa and mon mothman all those
people because whenever palpatine
sends the grand army of the republic to
the banking system and their whole clan
he's filing war on the banking system
and whenever the clones win that system
he now that essentially is saying he's
created a central bank he's created a
central treasury that is now
specifically and
strictly owned and operated by the
republic
slowly becoming the empire and that's
kind of that nail in the coffin and
that's when bail organa and mon mothma
and padme are trying to give a bunch of
speeches that kind of revenge of the
sith and a lot of the tale into the
clone wars and they're uh they're really
fighting as hard as they can to keep
things from like that from happening but
clone wars season and then
so you already made me think that i
didn't twig so questions anywhere
because i'm 80d and i can hop off the
mall mirroring
real policy
politics we are um so central bank
sounds like when 1940 you know 1938 when
the federal bank in the united states
was created
um so a centralized bank and they
started printing their own money and
they all went so this is marvellous
isn't it and basically america stopped
becoming a democracy
so that's one thing i think but the
other thing is so they've got all these
different clans and i got the trade clan
so that's is that supposed to mirror
the things like the fra in america
um fra is that right
the rifle association oh nra uh alright
sorry i don't know
and those sort of bodies that but we
have a little bit in them in britain
we have do they do have some but not
like in america
not like not like you guys have to deal
with where these
big
we don't have that so much in the uk
and we have like the prime minister will
occasionally buy somebody dinner and
that's about um as close to like
corruption as we get or at least our
corruption isn't all organized as
corruption in the united states
um
you've industry you industrialized
everything in the united states even
your corruption
um but is that is that what it's
what's sort of it's supposed to reflect
then because i mean just in that case is
evil just behind palpatine
well i mean yes and no so the best
person to
very much yes because the 1940s is kind
of of course where the original trilogy
almost begins and because it's very uh
it's not mimicking
it's close to mimicking i guess american
politics in a lot of ways palpatine is
essentially richard nixon is a good way
of thinking about things
uh and grandma tarkin could even be jfk
because
the wars he put into place uh
and then the continuation of all all the
uh
you know but politics and wars and
superseding powers and all these things
yeah
uh
i'm so clipping the richard nixon is
palpatine
yeah that's getting clipped
you know uh
he's yeah
he he essentially tricked people into
believing he wasn't a crook
in front of their faces he literally
went on television was like at one point
not a cook uh but yeah i'm not a crook
packaging does the same thing over and
over and over uh
but i guess to get back to the
corporation um question
yes and no it's not necessarily like
it's not necessarily like i guess nra
type companies and things like that but
it is because those are the ones that
lobby the most
but i believe it's more focused towards
like uh your coca-colas your pepsi your
monsantos your fords your your
giant international corporations that
have
just as much say i mean
we won't get into it but
uh
your medicine companies that's who he's
talking it's your pharmaceutical
companies your monsantos the people that
grows everybody's foods the trade
federation essentially was
i guess the middlemen between all the
different planetary systems and they of
course made money off of being the
middlemen and that gave them enough
influence and power to be in the senate
which is um
a little insane
uh
give as many people representation as
possible but
corporations you know uh twisting the um
twist in the democracy of it though
isn't it as much as
more visible though because they
actually did have physical presence in
the senate rather than
through puppets
we we get bored watching it unless
unless you're a big c-span watcher for
anybody there that watches c-span on a
daily basis good for you but uh
watch something else that might be good
for your head as well
but that's kind of
what we get to watch uh in star wars and
they make it more interesting by you
know adding aliens to it adding
different people that look
so different from different places
um
okay
so i've already started to realize star
wars had more layers to it than i
realized i mean i i wasn't watching it
carefully enough because obviously star
trek is known for having layers
and i always also got more so
so okay so we got the different so in
that case then the separatists
in
the clone wars we're very much
considered to be
the bad guys
in in lots of ways
um
ish
ish
well that was all that's what i was sort
of going with really was in that in that
the senate considers them to be
at very least a nuisance
and they're being manipulated by
the dark side
so i mean that's what causes a lot of
the conflict isn't it's a separatist
movement but separatist
and separating or or having the right to
be your own nation surely he's in the
heart of
freedom isn't it
and that's why i i guess the prequel
trilogy is kind of roped into that's how
liberty dies
because all the people that are the
separatist movement end up being the
original trilogy rebels all those
species and everything because at the
end of the day palpatine is
xenophobic only wants humans and a
specific type of human even in type
inside of a suit to fight for him until
it becomes a little cheaper just to put
as many humans as possible somewhere
uh
which adds a whole different level of
elements to things but um yeah it's it's
the populist
kind of
taking charge versus uh
individualism i guess it's
you've got the whole thing with the
clones certainly with the the clone army
that they don't
i mean they only talk in the movie about
how
um obviously this this army is being
grown quickly and the the fear of that
and then obviously the jedi oh we've got
an army yay um but but they don't they
they skirt around the moral
side of that because i would say you
know that really reflects on slavery
that these
um these clones aren't free you know
they've been grown to
fight and that's it
you know um
so i mean that that really reflects to
uh
subscription in the military
what anakin's head's going through the
entire time he's uh in the second and
the third film
little annie
well yeah
but um but i mean they don't really like
directly sort
of say that in the movie and like say
that the people like why everyone seems
to be so dead against the drone army um
is uh the clone army sorry is because
it's that it's a threat that it's um but
they never really discussed the moral
issues with having a clone army that is
has no free will
well
thankfully we have the clone wars and
they they do a really good job of
stretching that out and allowing i guess
people to
see the clones for for
what they are they are individuals but
they are a larger part of a whole at the
same time
and of course they don't have
autonomy they don't have free will they
have close to free will and some have
better decision makings better decision
making than others
uh
but that is even decided for them who
has the better decision making who
doesn't the arc troopers versus
your average joe clone trooper versus uh
the clone commandos etc etc uh i think
one of the if you remember in
[Music]
it's great to see the bad batch is great
because of that
um those are troopers are fantastic also
i saw irony runs deep in star wars
damn right yes it does
uh
but if you remember in the clone wars i
think one of the best kind
of outwardly just spoken about
variations of like slavery and more so
mental slavery and what you're willing
to subject yourself to is do you
remember the zeigerian arc i know that's
just another name but uh the the cat
people that were the slaves i remember
enslaved anakin obi-wan and i think it
was just them two and uh rex i think or
maybe cody one of the two
uh
and and
anakin's not even really taken as a
slave again he's more hey will you be my
my
king essentially is what the zagarian
wants him to be or not even king i guess
she kind of wants him as a twilight
twilight little sex slave in a way but
uh
star wars is full of these things but uh
i think yeah
yeah
she does a really good job in just a
22-minute episode of explaining where
you're already slaves of the republic
you don't believe what you're fighting
for which anakin is stating frequently
throughout the films throughout the
television series he doesn't feel like
what he's doing is 100 right and then he
gets more excited and starts chopping
down more droids and you know it just
furthers his own uh mental capacity to
uh comprehend what's going on yeah
okay it's a it's a tricky and it's a
it's a slow but it's a very intricate
fall and not even a fall because it's a
more of a realization that everybody is
already phil
uh or fallen i guess is the
correct grammar there i suppose that's
the thing with the end of the third
of the original of the
the prequels isn't it when i say the
other drones to and we realize this has
all been one big plan
and that yeah palpatine has been moving
peop pieces around the board like a
chess set you know just like um
you really get to see that in a
attack of the clones it's it's almost
like
that's all a good animal farm comparison
where
oh
i think i wrote it down actually yeah
it's essentially attack of the clones is
where
it's where okay i guess phantom menace
shows you the democratic process is slow
complex and it's open to corruption in
general yeah but attack of the clones is
where you watch
if you were talking george orwell over
here it's where you get to see
big brother actually come into effect
you get to watch how
a decent democracy more so
representative republic like the united
states is that's why the whole thing is
just kind of uh an allegory for u.s
politics from like the 40s to the 70s
but
we get to watch
coruscant and all these other little
smaller bits and pieces of the galactic
republic at the time
except big brother they're like okay we
need that we
we're not able to fight off all these
people by ourselves we need that help oh
and they're gonna stay longer we're okay
with that but give us some more food
give us more munitions give us these
things make us feel comfortable and that
way we'll accept that and it's it's
so i mean most of it's it's like george
lucas said it's for 12 year old boys you
know it's for your middle school age kid
and uh it's so intricate for all that
you know i think that's why it's so bad
i mean because that's a big thing with
our freedoms and democracies that a lot
of people have got quite nervous about
the last few years
is that as we're threatened by things
like covered and
terrorism
and all these things because i mean
terror
runs through a lot of the the the
the original movies the the prequels as
well
clone wars weird
clone wars is that we're willing to give
away our freedoms
to feel safe
um and that it's at what point do you
are you no longer free
if you give away all these freedoms away
i mean because a lot of people don't
believe we're free in the west anymore
to
we're not free to really to express
ourselves
increasingly less yeah
i i would argue that you would no one's
free you you're only as free as it's
it's free that you don't hurt or um
force your freedoms onto somebody else
um um so but you're free as long as you
don't hurt someone else
um but you know how do you how do you
where's that line but we've given away a
lot of freedoms in the last few years
too
and we like saying wartime stuff you do
definitely you know militia law and all
these things
subscriptions i could mention
um
so going into the
the original the the or the good star
wars movies
um
i mean it always seemed to me
that the empire were
nazis
yes seem to i mean
the the imagery isn't
subtle with that i mean in particular
and that goes on to the the next three
movies as well the imagery of the nazi
uniforms it's not subtle i mean they're
called stormtroopers for god's sake
was a rank in
hitler's army i don't know what it was
uh
but yeah i don't know the i guess all of
what tarkin's wearing and all the
imperial officers are wearing are quite
literally just a
slightly different
uh reconditioning of a nazi like officer
uniform kind of made a little more
spacey of course but uh it's it's very
on the nose very very on the nose yeah
it's not supple um so
in that one the republican storm an axis
it also assumes me that han solo is 100
a drug dealer
that was the only thing that i ever took
away from the first star wars movies
um
and
criminality was was was rife anything it
was
it kind of reminds me of like um saddam
hussein's iraq before we went in and
gave them all freedom i'm sure they're
really grateful about
is that actually he he ruled the country
with an iron fist but actually people
got to go to school they all had jobs
who led full bellis um and don't get me
wrong he was insane and he used to play
this thing called human chess
and when a piece took another piece you
got a rifle and you shot the piece that
had been taken
um so it was mentally
but the empire is a bit like that that
everybody seemed to be all right
yeah
well that's where i guess george lucas
was like
i guess i mean this was all presented
first but that's where populism is at
its forefront and it's it's hard to be
your own person i guess in that and the
people that are trying to are having to
fight quite literally for their lives
and for other people and those people
that they're fighting for most of the
time don't even realize what they're
fighting for might be better and it
probably won't be better at first you
know but that's why they're comfortable
and they're pushy and that's why luke is
even talking about joining the empire at
the very beginning of a new hope he's
like yeah that sounds like a good job uh
and he doesn't outright say that's a
good job with a dental plan and some
health insurance and all that but we can
only assume it's going to come with
those type of things uh it's probably
the most secure thing anybody can get
in the entire galaxy well they are the
government
at that point
um i mean that this way i'm looking
forward to and or as much as i am
because i think we're going to get to
see the build-up and the
the birth of the rebellion
um
i always thought it was the most
pathetic rebellion
they only had four ships
um
but just in that one little spot of
course
yeah that it didn't seem to be a very
well organized rebellion
but anyway or well well funded or well
supported
there seemed to be
two or three hundred people in a galaxy
of billions
that didn't like the empire and everyone
else seemed to be okay with it or
they're just scared
yeah no uh i really hope andor does a
lot and i guess
expanding upon that rebels does well by
showing did you ever watch rebels as
well as clone wars uh i can't remember
if i were tribbles i'm not made to
myself for a few years what's harris's
opinion on the rebel series that is my
favorite star wars there is sorry i just
read that as we were literally talking
about it
uh
rebel starts off shaky the first season
is very child oriented i don't think
it's as bad as a lot of people claim it
is but the second third and fourth
seasons i think are some of the best
star wars content made
um i don't even like saying the word
content
the star wars
filmography television made
uh
but
i i guess where
rebels shines is
yes thrawn is amazing uh
but where rebels shines is it
shows you i guess that the rebellion is
a lot more than just that one small
little sect of the rebellion we get to
see in the original trilogy it kind of
it demonstrates that yeah that was one
little small aspect of a much larger um
force
i mean the rebels had uh the reason that
the mon and calamar were even there you
know admiral ackbar and all that good
stuff
their whole planet was fighting against
the empire because they'd been
wrongfully taken over they were one of
the first planets that were taken over
by the empire they were like no no if
you're turning into an empire we're out
and the empire said no we're in and they
went in and uh
yeah
hopefully we get some
while we're exploring the bad batch and
all these type of things hopefully we
get some cool stuff around that around
this time because
you do remember uh
oh i got my star wars names but king
i don't i i i'm trying but king uh king
of the mountain calamari the uh
from the clone wars do you remember the
underwater arc where the king of the
world
it's gotta be fried really fast though
where it goes all chewy
and
korean barbecue and just get a nice
little grill on there one of the two oh
yes let's do that
we have korean bbq in vegas not to
derail anything but huh
that that was delicious dude with me
we're gonna do
here we got this exclusive we're gonna
do we'll go to vegas and we'll do a
sidetrack convention let's meet you in
store me
tell me when i'm there anybody else
wants to come they can't but we'll
pretend it's for work and we'll just go
get [ __ ] up
we'll do a stream or something like
in the middle of the casino we'll do it
in the middle of the bellagio so they
try to kick us out as quickly as
possible oh yeah any anyway
anyway we should go to a sci-fi
convention and actually do it properly
but it'll be more fun just to go and get
messed up so
but anyway what were we talking about
uh
just i i guess rebels and clone wars and
things but yeah
so if we if we're doing the analogy of
mexi germany then all right yeah so
which is true in nazi germany
a lot of the germans
um the german nation which is it's not
the the germans weren't bad people they
were just people that had children and
like food and stuff and a lot of them
they they worked for the nazi party they
even became members of the nazi party
even though they didn't want to but
because it was the only way to get a job
and to work you know and to survive and
to make a living so there wasn't really
a large-scale organized rebellion it was
quite small little pockets within the
german
country
during the war um i mean it became
more towards you know as towards the end
of the war and there was organized
rebellions um but really there wasn't a
large rebel
alliance
yeah
it is
reminiscent of that like it's
it's very reminiscent how jar jar took
power i mean how jar jar took power how
palpatine took power using jar jar
yeah he's jar jar is
the whole germany back in the day
um
being
not excited but it is excited for
the possibility of
of betterment for their own country for
their own peoples where that's just very
very misconstrued and as i guess hitler
was even democratically elected
chancellor of germany back in the day
he just like palpatine kept giving
himself more and more power and uh
that is
i like it a lot because it's an allegory
for the united states government always
and it's like okay these these
presidents keep getting more and more
power like that that third branch is no
longer a third branch it's kind of like
one-third of three branches and it
always has been but the other two are
supposed to keep one in check and
of course they keep each other in check
as well but uh
it really goes to show when that one one
voice has power for all of everyone's
voices things really start to get bad
quickly um
there was even and within to focus on
the analogy between the nazi party and
there was um the night of the broken
glass i think it was called
and there was a very violent incident
just after hitler became chancellor and
the the reichstag got burned down
um and that was really what secured his
power he he took out
any any because he was very shaky
initially it is with his strength you
know and they were become very close to
going bankrupt and which is why the
conflict had to start but
um
you know that there was a there was
which again mirrors i think in the first
three where we have that that one night
where the clones turned on the jedi so i
think um it almost feels like that
put them anyway we're into the um we're
into the the the the proper movies the
the good star wars films yeah even i
like those three
oh they're
fantastic
well they're they're cheesy fantastic
but they're they're fantastic
uh
yeah no that that's that's really
similar it's
that's
populism
sounds like a good idea sounds like a
good idea sounds like a good idea until
it isn't
uh not everybody's always gonna
agree with the whole you know
um and that's where those smaller
rebellious groups will pop up
everything
individuals are quite clever
individuals are thoughtful and um
caring and and are balanced in their
opinions
people
together are stupid and like to burn
[ __ ] down and um get very angry over
over even the slightest thing um
it's it's like i mean it's tribalism
it's whenever we
stop questioning something and we're
like all right well this person said it
so it's got to fit into my certain set
of beliefs and i'm going to do whatever
that person says and it doesn't work
well the only
we won't get too far into it of course
with the sequel stuff because there's
just a lack of a political identity
within the sequel trilogy uh
and and
i'm not saying that from like an outward
point of view i'm saying that from like
an inward star wars politics point of
view there there might have been
outwards politics that's a whole
different discussion but
the the the sequel trilogy in itself one
of the only like political things that
happens is at the very beginning of
force awakens when finn is questioning
orders that's one of the very very very
few times in all of star wars you see a
storm trooper even
think about questioning orders it's just
at that point it's what they do it's a
tribal kind of warfare and they're going
for it uh
have their orders and they're going to
follow them through
and they are individuals aren't they but
they're
they they are still
that's why
they are grown aren't they though he's
not
or they kidnapped i forget
they're in the corner
and grown they're all kinds of things i
guess but then they're uh aren't they on
drugs or something they're they're on
something aren't they and oh they have
to go conditioning when he starts to
break and starts to argue don't they say
something like send them back to
conditioning or something
yeah
they have all kinds of things that's
kind of i guess a little bit of what we
get to see when kylo ren is trying to uh
probe ray's mind in the force awakens
force awakens does have some decent
things it's just retreading on similar
ground it introduces a few small things
uh
the the inner politics of star wars just
kind of dissipates which
people kind of wanted at the time
because the prequels were so politic
heavy that
they got boring at times uh now i can go
watch that and
that those politics scenes make me just
as happy as the action scenes but
in a movie theater it would not you know
uh
well let's focus on a new hope for a
minute then so so a new hope the
politics it's it we think it is
nazi europe is that is that basically
what we're what where where the plot is
it
it's
it's essentially
nazi america taking over europe as well
okay interesting way of saying it
because all the politics are political
politics with the
with the within with the nazi gleam on
it i guess as a way of saying that
uh just because that's an easy way for
us visually to say back you know
um and it was just pretty
straightforward but the politics itself
are of course palpatine's richard nixon
and all these little smaller uh
kind of
things that lead up to where they're at
um
is it less nazi is nazis a nice analogy
because there's they are
if anybody says anything about evil
government or evil thing people always
go straight to nazis yeah that's easy
it's just easy isn't it it's where our
heads go and the uniforms and the or the
the imagery but is it really about then
not is it not really about nazis is it
about
things more like
the military-industrial complex yes the
so is it more like
big government
government with a big g rather than
think and and how absolute power
corrupts and
so in that case all the stuff donald
trump was talking about
um i don't know i said trump i'm sorry
um but i mean he
was using the populist opinion the
government is bad
to
even though he was in the government and
he did nothing to try to change anything
he that's why he kept
because he was preaching to your
emotional brain rather than your thought
brain wasn't either yeah this this [ __ ]
and it's his fault
so thanks is it more about that more
more than just generally government is
not necessarily a good thing
it's uh
yes and no again because if you're
talking prequels it shows that
while it also shows that too too strong
of a government can be a bad thing it's
also simultaneously showing that too
weak of a government can be a bad thing
if you have a government you need
you don't need anything i guess but uh
if you have a government you want them
to do what's best for the people and
that is a very skewed uh
reality it can mean so many different
things for however many different
peoples on different planets etc uh
different portions of the galaxy the
inner rim the mid rim the outer rim
the uh the wild space over here where
the tucks were in the tuck space
hut space
egyptian mythology in here real quick uh
i am going to actually so just bob's
made a point here and i'm actually going
to back up on this one i'm not sure the
richard nixon analogy is a particularly
good analogy
because richard nixon actually wasn't he
was considered to be a very good
politician
he was just corrupt and got caught
yeah george lucas george lucas has said
it's richard nixon i i that's i don't
necessarily
100
think it follows he
more bullet point followed a little bit
of nixon
the uh
expulsion of nixon and then into i mean
because the third film where the empire
strikes back and a new hope are
kind of
american politics in
the 60s
uh
while it's showing more i guess visually
from politics from 40s
by the return of the jedi like we
mentioned a little bit ago uh i guess
that was before we got on here but it's
the viet cong return of the jedi it's a
vietnam war and it turned and that is
where nixon's analogy kind of is cranked
up to a whole different level
yeah i mean nixon very much because he
was
i actually don't think he probably was a
good politician and he's not an evil
person so that's where the help
but he was corrupt and he was under the
thumb of the industrial military complex
and that's why he ramped up
the vietnam conflict
um
in my opinion anyway um remind me to
come back to the chasing amy mark just
give me do me a favor mate i haven't
seen chase and amy in about 10 years can
you remind me the scene because i can
only vaguely remember it
just quickly make a note and just remind
us what it is because i know it's
brilliant but i can't i can't think of
the detail and while he's writing that
out if he comes back to us
and we'll carry on but um
so yeah so the the new hope thing is is
that buildup and then um so you find
when we go to
fight with the
ewoks um so then
they're the vietcong
which is just an interesting thing to
think about that george lucas in the 80s
was already like
let me piss off a couple people real
quick
um
but nobody got pissed off because they
didn't realize what he was i think about
until 2033
so i certainly think the ewoks are the
greatest warriors on on in the galaxy i
just think you just send a bunch of
ewoks into any conflict for me it's like
um the british army we've got um
uh the oh [ __ ] sake the name you just
got on my head ewok uh yeah we've got
the gurkhas
he's got the gurkhas from everything and
then they're these little fellas but
they just don't stop fighting they'll
just that obviously i i'm just
remembering that bit from um is the
monty python holy grail where they like
cut his arm off because
it's a flesh wound come back here
and that's the gurk because that was
like uh you know a grey they'll go off
in the head and just like just scrape
the shrapnel and they're like this come
on let's keep going they're mental
the ewoks of the gurkhas for me oh pound
pound per pound those things are by far
the most dangerous thing
i love uh
would you rather a a wookie if you're if
you're going to have someone help you in
a fight i guess would you rather have a
wookiee or tin ewoks
i'm just half a pound those things are
traditional
um because as well i want to know how
they got you know those were massive
logs they got and they swung down and
smashed the attic i guess how's that
those little fellas get those up there
that is good
they're they're little bears
yeah they're vicious little
things and they were going to eat
everybody too if it wasn't thanks to all
golden c-3po
yeah we never remember how cute they
were they weren't ready to eat those
and somebody said to me that ewoks were
what's it uh what's it called when you
edit personally it's another person ah
my words i forget i'm struggling with
words
um but that's what they said anyway they
said that the ewoks were like goes no
because the ewoks
you would just have to eat another ewok
for that to be for them to be uh
cannibals thinking and then three
cannibals they're just that's just like
you're seeing a cow
hungry
yeah
yeah you always got skills boy
i i if you've ever played star wars
battlefront the the newer one the second
one loves that good
the ewok hunt is great i would like a
like a short film or even give us just a
smaller film but just someone trapped by
ewoks and having to escape them would be
have you ever seen pansies hunting down
uh going hunting
it's honestly go google it later
chimpanzees hunting videos it's
terrifying right
um they're vicious and that's what i
imagine ewoks
to be like we need ewoks to be back in
one of these movies soon and i just want
to see the eos just go mental and turn
some fakes off
take him off that moon and let's do
something
jedi just
tiny lightsabers running around
i just thought you know ever see the uh
those videos with like the the guy
who designed the um vent
um on the death star he's like ah come
on guys this goddamn space was this
nobody tell me about space wizards and
how did the torpedo get sucked in i want
to see another video that i like the guy
that decided to put the the transmitted
thing on that planet on that moon and
then the er somebody going did you not
notice the ewoks
little teddy bears wouldn't be able to
do that
they were living in the trees what were
you supposed to do like
they were the world's greatest warriors
they remind me of red pandas mixed with
actual bears
can you remember how the theme tune for
the ewoks cartoon went
you're too young see it's like it
literally went it's the e e
e
e walks and that was how it started and
that's something i could remember about
it and the ewoks had they had flying
things they used to fly you know we used
to we actually saw the gliders more
but uh are the ewoks race
ewoks are like the muppets
shelley might be a little bit obsessed
with um
with muppets
jim henson is great you know everything
jim henson
okay here we go they were saying the
star wars was racist and then they
brought up lando corazon and the other
guy brought up when they took off darth
vader's um black mask and it was a white
guy underneath
i'm gonna have to watch chase and amy
again
they had a lot of these little um rants
about stuff
i mean that that was a legitimate thing
back in the day but it was more so i
think
i wasn't alive during the time but i i
if i remember correctly it was more
after the empire strikes not yeah after
empire strikes back uh
no no it was after return of the jedi
after vader actually dies because that's
when you see him without his helmet and
you're like oh well that's not james
earl jones uh and i guess we
it might have been after empire strikes
back because luke i am your father uh
yeah
and obviously james earl jones not gonna
be mark hamill's bad
uh
but
it was a big thing back in the day but
i don't know i'm not the right person to
comment on that one uh yeah so i don't
think it was racist that they just got
this
see nowadays people go smoke
it's not woke it's why would you get a
black guy do the voice because he had an
amazing voice he had he was the best guy
for the job uh did you know what
he said you weren't
you have you seen the david browsey cuts
where it's david prousey talking as
darth vader on set
have you seen the video where it's um
the guy i can't remember his name but
the guy into his suit um and when he's
talking to um
solo when he's talking solo um they they
put in the
noises but in the actual filming
it's just him talking
yeah he said because then um he can
react better sort of thing because he
doesn't have to so the actor can react
better the harrison fall and
it's the weirdest thing to watch
it's so weird
it's sort of like this that by god oh i
think we should get the million falcon
going okay sulu let's start going you
know okay chewie let's do it it's just
weird go go google that guys if you get
chances it's really creepy to watch
but didn't kenny baker do the same thing
as r2d2
yes i think they did yeah didn't they
it's a little different because it is
animated uh but it is great the droid in
their chopper i believe
has more kills than any other star wars
character that we've ever seen on screen
including darth vader who has blown up
planets um
but
uh chopper's lines it's so great it's
dave filoni you know the guy that kind
of george lucas's protege
he's chopper but it's just him like
saying what the [ __ ] and all these
different like little uh cussing like
sentences and they just speed it up and
add like a little metallic twing to it
uh
and it makes every chopper seem
fantastic
star wars politics
just for a comment on there that uh
seriously it's so funny you need to
watch chase and amy back when kevin
smith used to make good movies and he
made dogma he's made absolute shout ever
since
um jay and silent bob reboot strikes
back whatever it was it made me laugh
no
no
it wasn't terrible
strikes back's got a line in it um he
is
jason muse is talking just
crap to his missus as normal and you
know into this girl he's trying to
because jay will you just say something
nice to me and he says uh you're my boo
boo kitty [ __ ] not just that game
my i used to say boo boo kitty [ __ ] a
lot
that sounds like something
to come up with that was the best thing
you could do to say something sweet
you're very excited for clerks three
nope not even a bit kevin smith hasn't
done anything decent for years
uh and it used to be dog bert is
generally one of my favorite movies i
adore it chase name he's brilliant i've
not seen it in years i used to love
watching kevin smith do his
it's not really stand up but he did his
like talks and things i've watched all
those multiple times
um i didn't hate he-man
um but i've pretty much hated everything
else he's done for probably 10 years
which is disappointing
yeah that matters the universe i
i didn't hate it but i didn't like it
either i could see what he was trying to
do i didn't even give it the time i'm
sorry
um
i i like kevin smith
rodrigo just did
i didn't hate it but i'll tell you what
no i'm actually going to rephrase that i
watched it because i loved he-man and i
can't wait for the he-man movie to come
out the kevin smith is nowhere near
thank god but he's done
yeah there's a human movie next year on
netflix a live action one
um if they don't have dolph do laundry
minutes at least in the park i don't
know what they're thinking
um
but um i'm not really looks like that
and he-man was my favorite cartoon when
i was a kid uh it was he-man 18 knight
rider airwolf for me that was my life
um
and then
he still he's done he did the
he-man series that he did and he did it
like he but he did it in the style of
the 1980s con of the cartoon and it
didn't quite work and the other thing to
remember is he meant barely in the first
is really annoying i remember pissing
off a lot of people uh yeah yeah i did
the second
second half series was better um but but
now it's still not good um so yeah i
loved i
i didn't hate it because it took me back
to my youth but actually if i'm honest
it was [ __ ]
um but anyway
with uh not not to derail or anything
but the whole warner brothers and
zazzlov and all that right now you know
they're they're looking for their kevin
feige
kevin smith has been tossed out there as
a person and
i love the guy he'd be a great person to
come on and like
give them advice and things like that
but he's a great indie move maker he's
not a great movie maker
unfortunately
he's a he's a good he used to be a good
low budget
pay maker
and he's a massive geek and you know
like thing but you cannot give that man
a proper budget he can't he doesn't have
to do it
i mean even his smaller budget films
like
i've got a little bit of a soft spot for
tusk but not that much of a soft spot
for tusk
uh they've been smoking a lot of weed by
that point
oh yeah and
it didn't bring him to any new
revelations
anyway we've devoted a little bit
we've gone on i don't know kevin smith
likes star wars too though so
he's a massive star i remember he was
saying about how he was filming
something and um he begged to go and see
the millennium falcon they're building
the millennium falcon for
um
[Music]
the new movies when they were building
new moves and then he got to go and he
did he rants he did a video on youtube
ranting for about 10 minutes about how
excited he was and now he is a massive
geek he's a massive comic book man
massive star wars fan so when he went he
distracted harrison ford and that's what
shut down uh
production for those few weeks right he
we're too excited we're blaming kevin
smith for that as well
he's already ruined my childhood you
know what really ruined my childhood
though was when in this country in the
uk we had some he-man adverts for um
uh
car insurance or something
like that and it had skeletal skeletons
and they're dancing in a nightclub and
then he goes oh skeletor and skeleton
and he runs over and does like that jump
from um
[ __ ]
um that uh patrick swayze movie my mom
that my wife likes uh
dirty dancing dirty dancing that is the
dancing thing and i'm like oh man
they've made he-man and skeletor a
couple and that ruined my childhood at
least kevin smith didn't do that
so
that would have been interesting did
mark hamill come to do the voice for
that skeletors he did do the voice for
skeletor
that's what it sounds like that's my
impression
there's going to be an inkling of
of soul area and there we go we've just
connected what we're talking about too
what we were just talking about because
what was in it perfect segway
excellent
we did that on purpose so of course
when we go into the
new
the last three movies then
the only politics i ever hear about that
is that we're going to just use the word
a little bit um
that it's woke
right
i've always thought bollocks um it's not
[ __ ] work um
but the big thing is around that um rey
is the mary sue and i thought well
do you think there's any
for me it was just i just saw she was
just she just mirrored luke's path in
the original three
that you know she
but they were saying well she never got
any training
she didn't have any training did she
and i'm like oh okay fair enough but she
does in the in the second movie because
goes find luke
so luke's yoda
huh
is luke yoder or is luke obi-wan there
she doesn't have an obi-wan in the first
movie that's the that's the one thing
she doesn't have but she then does have
a yoda in the in as in luke in the
second or an obi-wan whatever um
we should i suppose yeah um
i know because she's got him did she
she's actually i'm doing a hand sign
lifting up rocks with a brain and stuff
and she which is mirrors very much the
the the um the scene where he does the
same thing
and they even do the thing where they
tried to pull the tie fighter out of the
water don't they
yeah yeah that's kind of one thing
so so i'm going to say he's yoda but
so she did get the training in that
respect but people still go now she's
mercy
annoys me
well
i i can the thing that keeps me kind of
seeing where they're coming from because
i really like daisy ridley as an actress
i i like the whole crew behind all the
sequels it just
you can tell nothing was planned out and
you can that that's what gets me at the
end of the day is that the lack of
planning or george lucas he thought
about what
by the time he was writing a new hope
apparently at least he was uh thinking
about obi-wan and anakin fighting on
mustafar so he's got a whole whole
multiple trilogies in his head where
they're not even taking the time they
spend four billion dollars buying it
from george lucas not to plan out a damn
thing uh besides all right we want a
movie here we want a movie that's not
part of the trilogy here another trilogy
movie here another not trilogy movie
here and then another trilogy movie here
it's like all right that's
that's a plan but it's bullet points you
know it's it's more formatting what
you're going to do my i guess my biggest
problem with rey is not i don't
necessarily
she's not not necessarily a mary sue but
she's not necessarily a mary sue either
i my biggest fault with her is not that
she didn't have help on jakku anything
like that
what the hell is her backstory on jakku
how long has she been on jakku we saw
her parents leave and all that who
brought her to jakku we have absolutely
nothing but that she's been living by
herself for how long in an abandoned
walker that it seems dangerous every
time she goes in town so and we know
tattooing it's different than jakku but
there's tuscany
how would she how would a lone girl that
is she's young at the time but if she
would have grown up by herself on that
planet where she is
she wouldn't be alive where did she get
those skills
uh
and though is it because though because
of who she was and because
because that she had some sort of inner
warriors you know some people are just
born they don't have to necessarily be
trained they're just
fighters you know
if that's why she survives and why she
is the character she is and then why she
can't fight and why she you know
survives the uh
if they would have gone with any of the
three routes they would have taken from
the beginning like in the first movie
she was being set up to be obi-wan's
daughter uh
daisy ridley has said that she said oh i
thought i was you'll be one's kid and
then i was palpatines and the rise of
skywalker but in the second film
they cut out identity entirely no not
entirely but it's it's more of a self
finding your own identity versus
borrowing the identity from a previous
character to use as a parent or
something like that
uh
and
there was just no
they hadn't pinpointed anything
you couldn't really
get a grasp for what they were going for
because i don't think they knew what
they were going for uh especially thing
that they when they wrote the first one
that they hadn't planned where they were
going with it
because it did feel to me that actually
that the emperor reappeared at the end
that was never hinted at in the first
two films really was it did you get
hinted at the second one i can't
remember i don't think it would be how
palpatine returned
yeah and he built it
because they literally just say and
somehow palpatine returned
filmmaker
it it hurts the film yeah that makes a
little sick come up as well um
do you think they just thought
right we're painting ourselves into a
corner at the end of the second film we
don't really know we're going with this
one what do we do let's bring palpatine
back
okay how do we make that arc make sense
we'll make gray's daughter do you think
that was just like did literally live
looks like
we've got no choice here guys we need
something big to end this how do we
where we go how do we make it any bigger
than
we've we've brought back
harrison ford check for the first movie
everyone was very happy we've brought
back mark hamill check
and i'm prince we killed princess leia
and then brought it back uh check
how the hell where do we go from here
we've got to bring back palpatine
and they're
since
the the sequels are very very loosely
based off of the legends stuff obviously
with different character names and all
these different things they're not
legends by any means um
and of course i think that was more
disney trying to not have to pay a bunch
of uh
residuals to a bunch of different people
all over the place um
but
they the sequels are just
i don't know that
they lose me pretty pretty quickly just
i they don't they don't not lose me i do
like a lot of bits of them but i think
the thing that gets me at the end of the
day like you just said that they
it would make sense for palpatine to
return
in a lot of different ways of
of i guess the legends set up and in
some of the ways they set up the first
two uh
but to not pay that off in like the
first act
of
skywalker and to have it
and i mean i'm not i'm saying pay off
there really wasn't that much to pay off
all you can really think of is
uh there's a bunch of mysterious stuff
going on that we still don't understand
still i still don't understand what maz
kanata was doing in the sequel trilogy
at all
um i i feel like her
character could have helped delve some
of that mystery uh and pieced it apart
for us um
they were too focused on
i guess having each one of the original
trilogy members have their own movie
which doesn't even allow the new
trilogy people to have anything of their
own
uh and
just thinking about that that is that's
where my brain keeps going is we never
even got
i don't
mind the sequels as bullet points at all
i don't dislike them as bullet points i
don't like the way they were handled
but the my main thing there is we never
got carrie fisher mark hamill and
harrison ford on screen
at the same spot
ever again
and if you just need four billion
dollars in a product just thinking about
it purely as a product and then like as
a business who does that uh
why would you not take that advantage um
yeah
and i think it's one of those things is
be careful what you wish for maybe i i
thought harrison ford in the first one
was great i thought mark hamill wasn't
um i didn't think it worked and i didn't
think harry fishes worked you can
already tell she was not very well by
that point
um
but
it didn't it didn't work for me i
thought they're good films but they're
good films in that they're just good
like almost they're almost good action
movies
um in that there's there's not a lot of
depth and we're talking about the
politics and star wars here and we're
talking about how these things have
their metaphors for real life and for
certain or certain things about history
and which i think that's when sci-fi is
at its best when it's
do it and there's meaning behind this
in the last three there was no meaning
behind it they were just
action movies and the bloody the second
one was the second call i always forget
was called uh last jedi the last jedi
was almost like an action comedy buddy
movie and the bit worries they're all
the with the walkers and it goes and you
know mark hamill walks out and they just
go
and then he just does that
i'm just like [ __ ] off and then just
evaporate yeah yeah
yeah yeah um
so yeah now i'm with you on that one so
if we get into the disney tv series
before we before we come to an end
because we're already past an hour and
stormy always does this to me bastard
um
so
do you think that i mean like because
i'm thinking i love mandalorian i love
um i'd love boba fett particularly
episodes that he wasn't in um um and
i think andor is going to be amazing i'm
really looking forward to that
is it the same problem that that we love
them and they're brilliant tv shows and
they're really entertaining
but there isn't that maybe depth to them
that the original
trilogy had i i think we're getting to
that a lot they're they're learning
you learn i guess as a company doing all
these different things and they i think
they are learning but it's to a small
degree
and it's a slow role of learning
i think the sequels have the same issue
as seasons seven and eight of game of
thrones had
um it's just all right let's let's get
it out let's get it out uh
and you know both technically both of
those were lucasfilm's fault because
lucasfilm hired david binoff and d.b
weiss and they were like all right well
now we got star wars money let's get
game of thrones finished and hop over
they screwed that up and then got fired
by disney but
i mean that's just to talk about star
wars irony it always comes full circle
you know
uh
but i i even with the newer shows i
think they've learned that they need
depth
and that that is why they're so heavily
going back to the prequel trilogy and
going back to the original trilogy and
not they're not you know we all know
disney wants to have
their sequel
maybe not another trilogy but they want
their sequel characters the ones that
they can make the most money off of
because they don't have to pay residuals
anywhere at any of these other authors
or george lucas or anybody like that
these are brand new characters that's
who they want to be making things for
yeah they don't have the depth to do
that so they're having to go back and
and dig and almost find depth within the
places that already have it
to
even
give us something with soul i guess um
it's interesting it's a big universe i
just don't understand why they keep
going back to tatooine but it's a big
game
please i love that
anything else let's see what they do
with it because if the one thing we know
of certain disney will
drain every drop of blood out of this
stone that is star wars
that they can because that's what they
do
but
right well you've convinced me
i didn't believe you i thought you were
full of [ __ ] star wars star trek has
depth star wars doesn't have any depth
we're talking about
but apparently it does
talk about the uh
the real world aspect of things we
actually didn't even end up delving into
like the actual politicalization of what
they're doing with each other in the
films so there's there's a lot of depth
but i need to start drinking
but now i need a wii so um we'll call it
then we'll have to come back to it at
some point if the fans want us to uh
maybe you see star wars mrs predator yes
please
part of star wars
legally and technically et is one of the
uh races in the senate and the prequels
so we could get some yelling
right
thank you so much harris for educating
me it's been an absolute pleasure sir um
thank you for everybody that's been in
the um audience you notice how quickly
i'm trying to wrap this up because i
really really need a wii
so
thank you so so much we will see you
next week hopefully stormy will be
feeling much much better and
we will be back
see you guys say bye harris see y'all
yaya